questo è il motivo per cui nessuno fra i
video d'estate che tra l'altro mi faccio
fare aria da una piccola schiava cinese
ma nonostante tutto benvenuti ad un
nuovo episodio di pausa prima di
buttarci sull'episodio devo ringraziare
due persone assolutamente la prima che
mi son dimenticato di anche solo
nominale nell'episodio scorso che è il
dottor manhattan
il blog che porta avanti dottor
manhattan ha una rubrica che ha iniziato
molto prima di me che è molto simile a
pausa dove anche lui commenta i primi
episodi quindi io vi linko le
informazioni il mio preferito che
l'episodio di holly e benji andatevelo a
leggere perché ne vale la pena
non so se si vede ma sto proprio
gocciolano ci sono le gocce che mi danno
fastidio mentre parlo dicevo la seconda
persona è il canale di lì letta una
ragazza che fa una roba incredibile
riassume in pochi minuti le serie
animate e non solo quindi andate a dare
un occhio anche al suo canale perché
potreste trovare il riassunto della
serie dell'episodio di cui stiamo
parlando in pausa non credo di aver
azzeccato mile e l'italiano giusto per
la frase però avete capito a me va bene
non ce la posso fare
detto questo oggi tartarughe ninja oh
mio dio questa era una dei cartoni
animati che preferivo di più numero
piccolo che se però di scrivi a qualcuno
ad alta voce adesso capisci che era una
delle più grandi stronzate soltanto per
fare giocattoli e quindi danaro quattro
tartarughe geneticamente modificate che
diventano di ninja sotto l'addestramento
di uto fu umanoide per citare qualcuno
no non sono pazzo mia madre mi ha fatto
i test ma basta parlar a caso parliamo
del primo episodio delle tartarughe
ninja la riscossa
la puntata si apre nel futuro perché
dico che siamo nel futuro beh basta
vedere i primi fotogrammi dove si vedono
i teppisti classici teppisti del futuro
vestiti come se fossero usciti metà da
mad max e metà da full monty che
letteralmente disintegrano un'automobile
sembrava più livello bonus di street
fighter x ok
e siccome siamo dei culi gangster di
strada pitture amo le pareti perché fuck
the police e guarda che cazzo di
televisori avremo nel futuro non
possiamo rimanere indifferenti
prendiamo per esempio il caso di ace e
altro che 16 in ogni 4k novale il vero
futuro guardo il mondo da un oblò ma non
riesco a trovare la risoluzione giusta e
facciamo la conoscenza della rossa più
famosa del mondo
april o'neil casa hanno rubato due
acceleratori di positroni o un capello
capelli capelli capelli quest'uomo
spritz 1987 da tutti i pori da tutti i
nodi della cravatta che gli arriva fino
alle mutande qualcuno in città ha rubato
delle apparecchiature elettroniche e
guardate attentamente questa corda
evidente che opera dei ninja un antico
gruppo di guerrieri giapponesi sanità ad
esserne tanto sicuro beh c'è scritto qui
fabbricato in giappone
non sono sicuro se debba prenderla come
battuta o come vere e proprie tic e tac
con su scritto giappone su una corda
padrone c'è scritto fatta in giappone
c'è proprio scritto giappone a credo tra
l'altro è cambiata luce grazie mille
grazie mille il notiziario della sera
fini allo studio
che figo anche io voglio avere un'intera
leva solo per far apparire una
transizione ma qualcuno li sta
osservando schroeder il nemico
principale delle tartarughe ninja
ne parleremo dopo poi spiegano tutto e
non tardano arrivare i suoi scagnozzi
loro per esempio la telecamera su un
prendi la telecamera credo di aver
lasciato il ferro da stiro jazz accada
era palesemente troppo lontana da lui la
telecamera per poterla salvare ma april
o'neil che ha più [ __ ] dei suoi
collaboratori cerca di salvarsi la pelle
prendi e due
come cazzo ha fatto passare attraverso
un tombino non solo è talmente piccolo
che manca i topi ci passano da lì ma
c'erano anche due sbarre che lei ha
trapassato come se fossero disegnate
dietro nelle fogne e ormai chiusa da un
vicolo cieco april viene salvata da
quattro misteriose creature ei ma voi
non siete degli esseri umani brava
accidenti quante acuta la ragazza noi
sia dalle tartarughe
ok io lo so che non dovrei andare a
cercare il pelo nell'uovo perché sono
cartoni animati sono per un pubblico
giovane e ok però questo si basa c'è
pausa si basa anche su questo per
divertirci quindi è veramente difficile
vedere queste creature qui e subito
associarla delle tartarughe l'unica
descrizione che mi verrebbe in mente
quel momento lì sarebbe aborto verde ma
quella non è la realtà anche perché
altrimenti quella roba lì non sarebbe
mai potuto accadere quindi una tazza di
tè caldo e vico arrivato anche splinter
con palesemente dei cazzi disegnati
sulla capo toia topolino goloso e ridai
e che sviene
ed ecco uno dei marchi di fabbrica delle
tartarughe bagnarsi la pizza più
disgustosa del mondo e quella era una
delle robe che invece a sganasciare
dalle risate venere loro che mangiavano
stay pizzi improponibili e poi magari
andarle a chiedere a mia madre ed erano
dei dialoghi che poiché dicono sempre lo
stesso modo carino per che cazzo lo stai
studiando e qual è la prima domanda che
una donna fa quando si trova davanti a
quattro tartarughe ninja mutanti katia
mangiare quelle schifezze
ok e parte una scena che io non avevo
mai visto il flashback di splinter e le
quattro tartarughe
ecco
la mia storia e quella dei miei giovani
amici in realtà la storia di un uomo di
nome amato york il mio cervello in
giappone esiste un clan ninja ti prego
troppo stupido non dire quel nome
chiamato il piede lo ha detto il pm non
ho mai sopportato quello che era troppo
stupido e sprinter era uno degli allievi
di questa scuola uno che amava l'arte
letteralmente l'arte lui aveva un libro
con scritto arte che la cosa più
generale che potrebbe esserci mauro
cusatti uno dei suoi colleghi era geloso
e quindi accusa in modo falso sprinter
di voler uccidere il proprio maestro ma
come gli pianta davanti a tutti un
coltello sul kimono in modo che rimanga
bloccato al muro non si possa inquinare
e che quando lo toglie sembra che ce
l'abbia in mano per voler uccidere il
maestro così aveva intenzione di
uccidere il nostro onorevole sensai che
mi va bene come piano un pochino fatto
alla luce del sole ma ok
la mia domanda è perché cazzo non stava
dicendo nette lui ma parla di un santo
dei mogwai a mi ha messo il coltello
dietro la schiena non sono stato io e
stato lui invece no rimane zitto come
cazzo di protagonisti di alcuni
sparatutto dove gli succede tutto
intorno ma siccome il protagonista non
parla perché ha voluto così gli
sviluppatori non riesce a spiegare un
cazzo a nessuno e se la prende sempre in
quel posto sempre a e comunque il
maestro era la rappresentazione umana di
un ufo e infatti lui sì come viene
cacciato dalla scuola finisce a new york
ok giusto dietro l'angolo e vive nelle
fogne e tra l'altro è tornato il sole
chi è ma un bambino mentre stava
portando a casa sua credo 4 tartaruga
appena comprate a quanto pare inciampa e
cade da anche al tombino più grande e
più largo dell'intero universo
siccome dopo l'adolescenza io non l'ho
più seguito tanto le tartarughe ninja
non so se abbiano fatto una puntata del
genere ma io voglio uno spin off su quel
cazzo di bambino perché lui è la chiave
di tutto se quel bambino si fosse
allacciato le scarpe tipo non ci sarebbe
stata le tartarughe ninja
non ci sarebbero stati i film delle
tartarughe ninja e non ci sarebbero
di tutti i giocattoli delle tartarughe
ninja quindi bimbo meriti un applauso
durante il flash back che ci fanno anche
vedere come si è evoluto il clan del
piede e sono diventati gli assassini più
brutali di tutto il mondo si sono messi
a distruggere distributori di coca cola
ea minacciare persone con il gelato in
mano porca [ __ ] o mio dio ma a un
certo punto come tutti sapete ormai cade
del liquido un po gen o sopra le
tartarughe
fermiamoci un attimo vorrei che vi
fermaste a sentire per bene cosa dice
splinter per quanto riguarda questo
liquido ed è di nuovo andata via la luce
per davvero
bastava toccarlo per assumere le
sembianze dell'ultimo animale con cui si
era stato in contatto assumere le
è stati in contatto e come c'è qualcosa
che non va perché l'ultimo animale che
lui tocca sono proprio le tartarughe
ricoperte del fluido e lui si sarebbe
dovuto trasformare in tartaruga perché
ha toccato le tartarughe invece si
trasforma in topo e io veramente sto
rompendo i [ __ ] su questo
particolare in una puntata di un cartone
arrivata del 1987 olio bio la mia vip
loro chiamano lui splinter e lui chiama
loro con i nomi di quattro pittori
rinascimentali io personalmente con la
mia memoria di merda ci ho messo anni ad
associare i nomi ai colori delle
tartarughe o alle armi delle tartarughe
ma guardando la puntata mi sono accorto
di una cosa che io non avevo mai in vita
mia notato le tartarughe anno come
fibbia della cintura
la lettera iniziale del loro cazzo di
nome sono ricordato ma april non ci sta
e pensa che siano stati loro siano state
le tartarughe a rubare gli attrezzi e i
tecnologici è stato accertato che i
ladri erano ninja e si ma sei sicura che
fossero tartarughe le tartarughe
convincono hoepli che non sono stati
loro
e iniziano una caccia agli indizi per
capire da dove iniziare insomma
pizza ninja è la prova inconfutabile di
ciò che cercava è l'indizio che ci
porterà nel cuore dell'impero lynch non
solo ragazzi questo significa che fra
poco mangeremo la pizza e questa è la
faccia di una tartaruga ninja cui piace
la pizza una scimmia che ha appena avuto
un infarto
accidenti così non potete andare in giro
dovete camuffare il vostro aspetto che
ha ragione per i quindi è giusto che lei
prenda dei vestiti da uomo nel negozio
chiamato vestiti da uomo si trovano i
libri d'arte chiamati arte si trovano i
vestiti e uomo chiamati vestiti da uomo
dopo essersi vestiti tutti da tenente
colombo inizia ad indagare per bene vuoi
giocare alle tre carte taglia il razzo
coraggio lui ha detto taglia le carte e
lui ha preso una spalla e ha tagliato a
mentre sono nella pizzeria ninja ebri
capisce che c'è qualcosa che non va con
le telecamere di sicurezza e quindi va
direttamente negli uffici del servizio
di vigilanza
certo che indossiamo aiutarvi noi
abbiamo protezione moltissime ditte di
apparecchiature scientifiche da lei
starà tranquillo signore signori
ronaldinho e lì ci sono proprio gli
scagnozzi del clan del piede ma april
non fa in tempo a contattare nessuno che
viene rapita
che cos'è raffaello una lettera
minatoria no è il conto molto peggio è
il conto però già posso fare ogni
battuta una pugnalata al cuore
seguendo le tracce lasciate da happy il
suo tesserino la sua borsa appesa al
soffitto le sue gomme al gusto di melone
nella sua tessera di riconoscere passata
di qua solo lei mangia le circa al gusto
di melone arrivano sul tetto del palazzo
dove è pieno di scagnozzi
e qui parte finalmente una delle cose
più belle del cartone animato le scene
d'azione
cosa ha fatto cloud ha fatto planck ha
fatto ha fatto klang e ancora oggi non
riesco a capire che cosa cazzo mi piace
se torta organizza probabilmente ero
piccolo io e il tutto finisce spingendo
addosso a tutti quanti un intero muro
inseguendo altri scagnozzi sul tetto di
fronte si ritrovano in un palazzo molto
particolare prima di tutto trovano una
delle telecamere di shader guardate un
apparecchio trasmettitore molti video
digitale si o telecamera semplicemente e
ma qui dobbiamo ricordarci che è il
futuro è qui si assiste ad un'altra cosa
che io non ho mai più visto in nessun
altra puntata
state tranquilli state seduti e per chi
non l'ha vista preparatevi ad avere la
vostra infanzia completamente esplosa in
questa scena schroeder si toglie la
maschera maledizione sono le tartarughe
chiamato yoshi quelle bestiacce non
devono assolutamente scoprire il mio
tecnico è comunque shader per batterle
tartarughe una volta per tutte fa
scattare il suo trappolone riempire
d'acqua tutto quanto
si vede letteralmente il palazzo
riempirsi come se fosse un bicchiere e
non solo ma innanzitutto ricordiamoci
che questo è uno dei palazzi più grandi
che c'è nella zona ma c'è talmente tanta
acqua che fuoriesce dal tetto e diventa
un enorme fontana e come se non bastasse
esclude in mille pezzi
un grattacielo è nessuno dice niente
come se non fosse successo nulla e il
tutto finisce con un'altra pugnalata al
cuore
ovviamente di temi c'è niente che voi
tartarughe prendiate sul sergio è ciò
che c'è e sarebbe è qui finisce la prima
puntata di tartarughe ninja
che dire me lo ricordavo molto meglio
poi c'è da dire che secondo me il
cantone arrivato delle tartarughe ninja
è stato creato si tratto dal fumetto
verrà completamente diverso prima di
tutto dal fumetto per essere diciamo è
più adatto ad un pubblico molto giovane
ma soprattutto è stato fatto per vendere
giocattoli e ci sono riusciti e ci è
stato periodo in cui le tartarughe ninja
erano ovunque
alla fine secondo me non è che ci fosse
da fare molto con questo cartone animato
e fa quello che deve fare cioè far
vedere quattro tartarughe ninja che se
menano coi nemici fine grazie mille per
essere basati anche in questo episodio
di pausa sono contentissimo dei commenti
positivi del primo video sono molto
contento che vi sia piaciuto
io lo porterò avanti perché diverte
anche me questa cosa qui è o almeno
l'occasione di vedermi anche i primi
episodi
grazie mille e al prossimo pausa